the New York Times his newest editorial
hire has a controversial history a woman
writes about why she wishes she had a
border her down syndrome child and
Barack Obama stabs Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez directly between the
shoulder-blades I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
oh we have so much to get to today
really a lot of news and an analysis all
the things you've come to know and love
here on the bench Shapiro sir I would be
remiss if I did not note that we do have
a couple of events coming up in just a
couple of weeks now in Dallas in Phoenix
if you have not yet bought your tickets
now is the time to do so we're running
out of tickets quite quickly Dallas and
Phoenix again that's happening in a
couple of weeks go to daily wired.com
slash events for all the information on
that also if you are just in a mood to
enjoy life a little more than you are
currently enjoying life well I have an
excellent thing for you and that thing
is wink it's hard to believe but even I
occasionally need to unwind and when I
unwind sometimes I like to take a drink
of water but you you need wine and the
fact is you should go check out wink
because wink has the best wines not only
do they have the best wines they also
ensure that your wine is actually
tailored to your palate wink makes it
easy to discover great wines because
winks wine experts selected wines match
to your taste personalized for you
shipped directly to your door and
starting just 13 bucks a bottle folks at
the office love wink wine we've had
taste tests at the office before let's
just say not a lot gets done the rest of
that day but you can go check it out
right now at wink comm you take their
palate profile quiz they ask you
questions like how do you take your
coffee how do you feel about blueberries
and then wink sends wines curated to
your tastes the more wines you rate the
more personalized your monthly
selections each month there are new
delicious wines like the insanely
popular summer water rose a no
membership fees skip any month cancel
anytime discover great wine today go to
try wink comm slash Bennett's t ry winc
comm slash Ben we get 20 bucks off your
first shipment that's try winked calm /
Ben for 20 bucks off your first shipment
again try winked calm / it then okay so
in breaking news the New York Times has
decided that they are going to hire a
woman named Sarah Zhang to join their
editorial board now why is this relevant
to your life the reason this is relevant
to your life is because Zhang previously
wrote for a publication called the verge
and authored the Internet of garbage
which is a book about online harassment
and free speech a problem for Sarah
songs that people actually went through
her old tweets and some of the things
that she has tweeted in the past are not
particularly great she has tweeted
things like this quote dumbass effing
white people marking up the internet
with their opinions like dogs pissing on
fire hydrants is back in 2014 so not
supremely long ago but a few years ago
our white people genetically predisposed
to burn faster in the Sun thus logically
being only fit to live underground like
grovelling goblins hashtag cancel white
people
oh man it's kind of sick how much joy I
get out of being cruel to old white men
I dare you get on Wikipedia and play
things white people can definitely take
credit for it's really hard this is
Sarah drawing the new New York Times
editorial board author white men are BS
no one cares about women you can
threaten anyone on the internet except
cops
I just realized they're all old tweets
of hers and she was hired I'm sure the
New York Times if they if they didn't do
a background check on the person they
hired over at the New York Times then
they were entirely Ramez they say I just
realized why I can't stand watching
Breaking Bad or a Battlestar Galactica
the premise of both is just white people
being miserable and she also tweeted
white people have stopped breeding
you'll all go extinct soon this was my
plan all along so she seems like a real
delight this Sarah's wrong person I have
been told that she is basically one of
the more brilliant people out there and
that these tweets are not indicative of
her prior work which I'm willing to hear
but by the rules of the left this person
should now be excised from polite
society because that's how the rules
work on the left right the way that this
works is that if they unearth an old
tweet if somebody unearthed an old tweet
that nobody likes then we finish our
career we yell at you and we scream at
you until you stop being able to write
for a major publication like the New
York Times now should she apologize for
those tweets I think probably that is
merited is it indicative of the
mentality of the New York Times they
think it is appropriate to hire somebody
like this it is indicative of that
mentality because the fact is that if
anybody who is white wrote this about
anybody of any other race Sarah Jones
Asian if somebody who's white wrote this
about a black person or or Hispanics or
Latinos or Asians or anybody then that
person would be out of a job forthwith
in fact if you're Kevin Williamson and
all you did was make a joke one time
about hanging women for abortions then
we kick you off the staff of the
Atlantic if you're me and I say that I
don't like rap and I am a racist and
Mark Duplass has to direct America PLAs
has to delete his tweet saying that I'm
a nice guy and you might want to follow
me on Twitter right the way this works
on Twitter is that if we find something
we don't like about you in your past
then we absolutely destroy your career
again it is indicative of the New York
Times's belief system that they are
pretty much fine with going after with
with their columnist saying stuff like
this because again if this were anybody
on the other side of the aisle you can
bet money that it would not
is easy on that person now will the New
York Times back down and fire this lady
I doubt it I think the New York Times
will probably maintain I hope the New
York Times does maintain I think it is
good to have a plethora of voices I
prefer more speech rather than less
speech I think it's also your decision
whether you wish to subscribe to a
newspaper to like the New York Times I
do not
you probably don't either but if you do
wish to subscribe then maybe you want to
give that a second thought that is your
prerogative as well but it is again
telling that the same folks on the Left
who suggest that you are out of the
realm of polite discourse so long as
they deem it so are perfectly willing to
welcome into the realm of polite
discourse people like Sarah Zhong who I
assume is not even remotely as bad as
people like al Sharpton who has been
legitimately a race-baiting piece of
human debris for decades now so again
this is pretty telling about exactly how
the left operates when it comes to the
the opinions they seek to protect I was
talking with a friend of mine earlier
today who happens to be on the Left
issues a liberal and she also happens to
be black and also happens to be a
lesbian so she checks off a lot of the
intersectional boxes that a lot of folks
on the Left really seem to care a lot
about we were talking about
intersectional politics and she was
contending that America is basically run
on intersectional politics that identity
politics politics will recount about
your race your sex your ethnicity or
your orientation that these politics
have always driven the United States and
what I was arguing is one of the
problems that we're seeing right now is
that if you look at the history of the
United States in terms of how
intersectional politics has worked you
know race politics identity politics it
is fair to say that racial and identity
politics have declined markedly since
for example the 1960s but if you were to
create a scale of 1 to 100 of identity
politics well you would probably say is
that at the very beginning of the
Republic identity politics it was a
little over 100 because there were
actually black slaves and people arguing
that black people ought to be slaves
it's about as racist as it could
possibly be then after the Civil War it
drops to about a 70 on the scale of 100
because black people are no longer
slaves but we are going to suggest that
they are inferior if you're the dominant
American Society and you're going to
excise Asians and you're gonna excise
Latinos and all the rest of it and then
over the course of the next hundred
years it drops to perhaps 60 all the way
up to the end of Jim Crow and then it
plummets precipitously to the point that
when I was growing up I'm 34 years old
when I was growing up the worst
thing you could call somebody in America
was not a racial slur it was a racist if
you want to destroy somebody's life if
you want to make them feel awful you
call them a racist racist became the
slur dujour because everybody understood
that racism was a bad like the idea of
talking to people my agent saying to
them that certain people are genetically
inferior because of the color of their
skin
it doesn't even compute it doesn't make
any sense to people who are below the
age of 40 in the United States because
we've grown up in the post Jim Crow era
and we find all of that stuff abhorrent
so intersectionality took a nosedive
but now intersectionality is recovering
because the argument the left has made
is that America's was historically based
on the notion of white supremacy it was
historically based on racism from white
people and now intersectional groups
must have their revenge now we have to
have a reverse identity politics or
whatever you say about white people is
totally ok we never had our chance in
the Sun racism can only come from
dominant groups it can't come from
put-upon minority groups it's an
argument that's made by a lot of folks
on the Left a really serious argument
made by a lot of folks on the left that
if you see Sarah Shaw and Asians saying
racist things about white people it's
not actually racist because Sarah Zhang
is an Asian and Asians have historically
been put upon in the United States even
though Asian households have the highest
household earning capacity of any
households in the United States and
white Americans for example or in 76
cents on every dollar that Asians earn
in the United States you just average
out the salaries but the intersectional
idea goes and if you're Asian you're a
member of minority group therefore if
you are racist toward a white person
it's not actual racism and white people
are saying wait a second racism is
racism now listen I understand that
virtually all politics is reactionary I
understand that we all react to one
another and that there's a desire for
turnabout is fair play but if you want
to get to a society that actually means
something then we all ought to be
stumping against this sort of bigotry no
matter the source the problem is folks
on the Left have decided that white
bigotry is bad which is true but they've
decided that non-white bigotry is
totally okay because it is non-white
bigotry therefore it is not bigotry
because non-white people cannot be
bigots that's a very bad thing and it's
contributing to a sense of destruction
in America's politics in a pretty
significant way the intersectional
politics that have dominated our
proceedings of the over the last few
years are really quite disgusting now
speaking of disgusting I want to talk
about a piece
over at the UK Daily Mail because I
think it is again indicative of a
mentality on the left so we're going to
talk about a couple of ideas today about
where the left is going so the left is
moving in a couple of different
directions so direction number one the
left is moving is in this intersectional
direction where race matters more than
anything else and certain races are more
valuable than other races and we can
determine whether your opinion is good
or decent or valuable or worth listening
to based on the color of your skin or
the formation of your bone structure
right we can tell all of that just by
looking at you whether we ought to give
you a listen or not that's point number
one in the left's new agenda point
number two in the left's new agenda is
that all moral standards are subservient
to your suffering that we ought to give
you leeway because you've had a hard
life this has been part of leftists
trope since forever basically I mean
even if you go back and you listen to
West Side Story the song gee officer
Krupke is based on mocking this trope
that people who are juvenile delinquents
are only two butyl delinquents because
they've been put upon in reality people
are juvenile delinquents very often
because they make a choice that is a
really bad choice and decides to be bad
people well the left has decided they're
going to double down on the idea that
you're allowed to do bad things so long
as those bad things make you feel good
that's what this article is in the UK
Daily Mail it's an article by a woman
named Julien Ralph
she's a 69 year old mother of a 47 year
old son his name is Steven there's only
one problem steven has Down syndrome and
that means that Julien wishes that she
had killed him before he was born
I'm not joking there's an actual like 8
page article in the UK Daily Mail the
piece is basically this heartbreaking
extraordinarily lengthy description of
how hard it is to deal with down
syndrome child
Julianne's care for her son is obviously
heroic this Gillian Ralph person read
she's taking care of her son who is
severely Down syndrome and and you know
can't take care of himself can't wipe
himself he's now 47 years old and all
the rest but here is what rel says she
says so difficult has it been that I
honestly can say I wish he hadn't been
born I know this will shock many this is
my son whom I've loved nurtured and
defended for nearly half a century but
if I could go back in time I would abort
him in an instant I'm now 69 and Roy is
70 Roy's her husband and we'll celebrate
our golden wedding anniversary next
month perhaps you'll expect me to say
that over time I grew to accept my son's
disability and now looking back on that
day 47 years later none of us could
life without him and that I'm grateful I
was never given the option to abort
however you'd be wrong
because while I do love my son and I'm
fiercely protective of him I know our
lives would have been happier and far
less complicated if he had never been
born
I do wish I'd had an abortion I wish it
every day if he had not been born I'd
probably have gone on to have another
baby we would have had a normal family
life and Andrew would have had the
comfort rather than the responsibility
of a sibling after we're gone instead
Stephen who struggles to speak and
function in the modern world has brought
a great deal of stress and heartache
into our lives and this is why I want to
speak in support of the 92% of women who
choose to abort their babies after
discovering they have Down syndrome okay
so the second point in the Democratic
platform first point is
intersectionality second point in this
idea that subjective pain allows you to
perform objectively sinful activities
we'll talk about that in just a second
first let's talk about your impending
doom okay you're gonna die someday it
may not be that far away I mean I know
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna hint at it
I'm not gonna hint that I know the
precise day upon which you applause I
may or may not know that but when you do
plots the one thing that you're gonna
wish you had done is get life insurance
and that's why you shouldn't waste your
time you should have gone over to policy
genius right now besides the life
insurance rates are the lowest they have
now been in 20 years the best time to
buy is now in the best place to buy life
insurance is policy genius calm policy
genius is the easy way to compare life
insurance online in just five minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers to find the best policy for you
and when you compare quotes you save
money it is indeed that simple policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance they place over 20
billion dollars in coverage and they
don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and renters insurance and health
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it for you so if you've been
putting off getting life insurance
there's no reason to do it anymore
go to policy genius com get quotes apply
in minutes it is that easy you can do it
right now and you should because again
the rates are their lowest in 20 years
policy genius comet is the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance go check
it out right now policy genius.com don't
leave your family without any cash in
your plots policy genius.com go check it
out ok so point one in the democratic
platform intersectionality point two
subjective opinion subjective feeling
Trump's objective moral standards so if
you're somebody who's had to suffer with
having to deal with a Down Syndrome
child you should go out there and you
should talk openly about the fact that
you wish to kill that person before
birth now never mind that's deeply
immoral never mind that having children
is is
always a sacrifice in in my case it's
also a joy because I thank God have two
healthy children even though you know
there are hard times including you know
we've had to have open-heart surgery on
our daughter that doesn't mean that pain
is a good excuse for for obliterating
another human life how many people who
are 60 years old have an 80 year old
parent who is suffering in the throes of
dementia does that mean that it's moral
to stick a stick a pin in their arm
stick a needle in their arm and just put
them down like a dog is that does it
doesn't mean that it's okay when
somebody is causing you insane amounts
of pain is it okay to go murder them
when that person is causing you grief
and pain and difficulty is it okay for
you to actually go and kill that person
of course the answer is no but in the
Democratic agenda it really is that our
level of sympathy is supposed to trump
objective morality and the value of
human life
so that's prong number two in the
Democratic platform all of this is is
peculiarly self-centered that if you're
a particular race you get to be as
vengeful as you want about another race
so long as you're not white and that if
you are suffering from anything in your
life you got to obliterate that thing so
long as Democrats say it's okay for you
to obliterate that thing and that brings
us to the third prong of the Democratic
platform and that is the economic plan
the economic plan of course is
democratic socialism so let's talk about
democratic socialism obviously this is
rising inside the Democratic Party
there's this great battle going on right
now inside the Democratic Party for the
future of that party there's sort of the
gradualist and then there are the
extremists the gradualists are people
like Barack Obama believe it or not and
Hillary Clinton people will believe the
can't go full-scale socialist without
alienating the American people and
disrupting the system so you have to
take it one step at a time we will move
toward more and more socialism more and
more restriction ISM in short order and
then there are the people like Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez I'm getting better their
name guys I'm saying right now Alexandra
of cosmic Cortes who says let's go
full-scale socialism right now does the
Bernie Sanders plan let's go full-scale
socialism right now well Barack Obama is
now sounding off on the 2018 elections
in a really interesting way so here is
what the president the former president
has to say he announced on Wednesday the
first wave of Democratic candidates that
he is endorsing for November in a series
of tweets he listed candidates in more
than a dozen states that he's backing in
2018 he wrote today I'm proud to endorse
such a wide an impressive array of
Democratic candidates leaders as diverse
patriotic and big-hearted as the America
they are running
I'm confident that together no strength
in the country we love by restoring
opportunity preparing our alliances and
standing in the world and upholding our
fundamental commitment to justice
fairness responsibility and the rule of
law but first they need our vote so who
exactly did he endorse well he endorsed
gavin newsom in california who is to put
it kindly a poop tornado jared palace in
colorado stacey abrams in georgia JB
Pritzker in Illinois and Richard Cordray
in Ohio he also endorsed a bunch people
in the house but he did not endorse
better o'rourke in Texas for example he
also did not endorse Alexandra Ocasio
Cortes now the reason that he didn't
endorse Alexandra Ocasio Cortez is
because he doesn't want to endorse the
most radical candidates he can find he
doesn't want to give that side of the
party impetus running up to the 2020
election Obama is a smart enough
politician to know that if Democrats
want to win in 2020 they have to present
a candidate who is not seen as too
extreme by the American people the
Democratic Party however is running full
scale toward embrace of democratic
socialism so obviously they've decided
to make their face this Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez who by the way it's really
bizarre that she's being treated as this
rising star in the Democratic Party
she else did Joe Crowley who is a
Democrat in her district and was this
this sort of well-known ten term
Democrat in New York the district is 50
percent Latino or 50 percent Hispanic
she is also Hispanic Joe Crowley is not
Hispanic she won with a grand sum total
of seventeen thousand votes in his
primary so she won 17,000 votes in the
primaries like as many votes out getting
a CPAC straw poll if she won that she
won in 17,000 votes in in this primary
and this makes for the new face of the
Democratic Party because she's 29 years
old and because she's kind of pretty and
because she she has a certain level of
charisma and enthusiasm even though she
doesn't know what the hell she's talking
about but the problem is that the
Democratic platform of democratic
socialism is too extreme for the
American people as well it should be but
now it's being treated as mainstream and
so there's a bevy of articles over the
past several weeks about democratic
socialism its rise why this is the
future of the Democratic Party and
there's a lot of talk in 2016 about how
trumpism was taking over the Republican
Party there were a lot of attempts to
say what trumpism was was Trump is's
trump ISM about protection of trade was
trumpism about subsidies to blue collar
white areas was trumpism about
protectionism and closing the border it
turns out that Trump is
basically just about Trump right
trumpism was about people liked that
president Trump is a puncher people like
the president Trump is aggressive
there's a wide variety of perspectives
about his policies but there's not a lot
of variety about people in the
Republican Party liking from personally
which is why he has such diehard loyalty
among his base but for the Democrats
there really is an ideological takeover
of this party that has happened since
2010 the Republican Party has not moved
in ideology since 2010 which is why
Trump is now implementing policies it
would be exactly the same in a Rubio
administration or a Cruz administration
or even a Jeb Bush administration except
for maybe on immigration but when it
comes to the Democratic Party their
actual policies have moved hardcore to
the left this is what Obama is
recognizing is that the Democratic Party
has moved to left again there are new
three prongs are intersectionality
complete subjectivism when it comes to
personal activity even an activity that
affects others and finally and most
importantly an embrace of democratic
socialism and this embrace of democratic
socialism is the one that's going to
absolutely destroy them
intersectionality alienates the middle
of the country at alienates white voters
the the subjectivity alienation
religious voters and democratic
socialism alienate to anyone with half a
brain
because democratic socialism does not in
fact work now in a second I wanna go
through some of the myths that surround
democratic socialism because there's
this this new kind of narrative that's
being put out by a bunch of folks on the
on the Left the democratic socialism is
different than socialism that we ought
to take it very seriously that if you
look at the United States what really is
missing is this sense of
redistributionist justice the social
justice that we need to bring about we
need to rectify income inequality by
moving toward more equitably distributed
resource base that's what we really need
but that's not really what democratic
socialism is about what democratic
socialism is about as a complete
takeover of the economy so let's jump
into seven myths okay there are seven
myths about democratic socialism that
are pervade by these advocates of the
new Democratic party platform you know
the Ocasio Cortez's and the Bernie
Sanders so first they claim the
democratic socialism is not the same as
socialism that is not accurate so
democratic socialism is the idea that
it's going to be socialism but we're
gonna vote for it and therefore it's not
really socialism well that's not what
social isn't means socialism is just
about the idea
from each according to his ability to
each according to his need as insured by
nationalization and centralization of
government resources and a
nationalization of industry socialist
programs redistribute socialist
economies abolish private property in
nationalized industry in order to
redistribute it's important to
differentiate differentiate these two
things so for example if you have a
socialist welfare policy that takes
money from some and gives to others that
is a socialist welfare policy it does
not mean you live in a socialist country
the United States is a capitalist
country with socialist programs right so
Medicare is a socialist program of
redistribution Social Security is a
socialist program of redistribution we
lie about it we say that it's you
putting the money in and getting it back
out but it's actually a socialist
redistribution program socialist
redistribution programs are socialist it
doesn't make the entire country a
socialist country it makes it a
capitalist country with a solid welfare
base which is still not ideal but we
have to be clear about what we are
talking about my nationalized health
care is socialized medicine but Canada
is not a socialist country Canada is in
fact a capitalist country with
socialized medicine it's an important
distinction we need to be clear about
that
and when democratic socialists say that
democratic socialism is different from
socialism not really not really they
need to be clear about what they're
saying myth number two is that
democratic socialism is not in fact use
of force so democratic socialists claim
that they aren't for overthrowing
democracy then what industry to just be
run by the people so factories should be
run by the workers and industries should
be run by the employees how are you
gonna do that though well what you're
gonna do is you're gonna go out you're
gonna vote for the government to take
over those industries and basically
regulate them into the dust okay that is
in fact use of force just because you
voted for the use of force doesn't mean
that the use of force is not being
applied if Colton and I decide that we
want to rob somebody else in this room
until we vote on it
then yeah you if we decide that we're
going to that we're going to rob this
young lady right here then that's still
theft right even if we vote on it that's
for it that's use of force and that's
theft because I assume she's not gonna
willingly give me her wallet and she
shouldn't because it's not my money okay
so the idea that democratic socialism is
not forced is of course very it's very
silly and socialism always tends to
degrade into force because what happens
if the people don't want socialism what
happens if the people vote against
democratic socialism what happens if
they vote against industrial is
nationalization of industry and quote
unquote democratization of in
what what if it they vote against that
stuff well if they vote against that
stuff then it must be because they are
emissaries of evil capitalist system
that bred them and so we must gulag them
we must send them out for re-education
to the gulags or must liquidate the
dissenters okay third myth that is
pervade by these these pushers of
democratic socialism is that socialism
is fairer right they say socialism is
more fair yeah I'm gonna talk about that
in just a second first let's talk about
your tooth health ok the reality is that
you don't brush your teeth twice a day
and you don't spend the requisite amount
of time on your teeth and then you go
into your dentist asks you about all
this stuff and you lie to your dentist
because everybody lies to their dentist
but there's no reason for you to lie to
your dentist instead just go get the
quip electric toothbrush quip is the new
electric toothbrush the packs just the
right amounts of vibration into a
slimmer design in a fraction of the cost
of bulkier traditional electric brushes
and guiding pulses alert you want to
switch sides making brushing the right
amount of effortless quip also comes the
mountain suctions right to your mirror
on sticks to use as a cover for hygienic
travel anywhere whether it is going in
your gym bag or in your carry-on and
because the thing that cleans your mouth
should also be clean quip subscription
includes a dentist refresh schedule
where you get a fresh fresh brush head
every three months for just five bucks
including free shipping worldwide
I've got quip it is fantastic I like not
having to think about one to replace the
brush head and the quip tooth brush
travels really easily which is why I'm
so angry at myself that I forgot my
equip electric toothbrush at home on
this particular junk on this particular
junket clip starts just twenty-five
dollars and if you go to get quip comm
slash Shapiro right now you'll get your
first refill pack free with a quip
electric toothbrush again first refill
pack free at get quip comm slash Shapiro
that's GE tqu IP comm slash up here I'll
go check it out you're not gonna want to
leave your equip electric toothbrush
behind go check it out quick get quip
comm slash Shapiro for that special
discount and deal okay so the the third
claim that is made by advocates of
democratic socialism is that socialism
is fairer socialism is not fair it is
deeply unfair fairness rests on the
basic idea that you get what you deserve
this is why it's really fascinating
there all these social science studies
that demonstrate that people will go out
of their way they'll harm themselves in
order to punish people who they feel are
cheating so if you play the there are
all these really interesting studies
where they'll put a group of people in
the room and you have a choice as to
whether you want to sacrifice some of
your own money
punish somebody else in the room or
whether you want to keep your own money
or whether you want to grab somebody
else's money and people who grab other
people's money are immediately hit with
people who will spend their own money in
order to punish those people human
beings have an innate sense that it is
wrong to take other people's money
without proper justification and without
any right to that money socialism seeks
to destroy consequences for actions
charity is based on the idea that we
ought to help people in need
socialism is based on the principle that
need creates additional rights this is a
very very different thing charity is
about my capacity to give and about my
obligation again socialism is about the
idea that if I am poor I now have
additional rights that I did not have
when I was not poor right simply by
virtue of becoming poor I now have the
ability to steal your wallet so when I
wasn't poor I if I stole your wallet you
would've said that I was a criminal but
now that I am poor and I steal your
wallet well that's for socialism hey
that's deeply deeply immoral stuff a
fourth claim that Democratic socialists
make is that socialism was not present
in the USSR or Venezuela or Cuba this is
what we call the no true Scotsman
fallacy anything that is bad isn't
something that you did right any any
communist country that ends in murderous
tyranny isn't actually communism or
Marxism though those are just miss
applications of the rule we've never
actually tried real Marxism if we tried
real Marxism you actually probably liked
it this is an argument that losers make
with regard to dating where a girl says
I don't want to date you because I've
seen how you date other people you like
right but you haven't tried it yet if
you tried it then it would just be it
would be completely different your life
would be so much better if you dated me
even though you saw how like I used to I
used to dine in yeah I used to dine in
ditch on that on my prior girlfriend
that wasn't that wasn't the real me once
you get to know the real me you'll
understand that I pay for the best
dinners in town if you believe that guy
you're an idiot and if you believe
socialist you say that USSR Venezuela
and Cuba are not socialist you are also
similarly an idiot the fact is that all
of these countries are stated Marxist
countries they all ended the same way
because when you take socialism to its
ultimate extreme which is
nationalization of all industry and
shutdowns a private industry through use
of government force you end up in a
pretty awful place pretty quickly which
brings us to the fifth claim the
Democratic socialists make and this is
the claim that they are using most often
right now that is the claim that
socialism is
what makes Nordic countries awesome so
what they will say you'll hear Ocasio
Cortez and Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren I'll say that when they say
socialism what they really mean is
Norway they don't mean but as way let
them mean Norway they don't mean Cuba
they mean Denmark there are a few
problems with this okay the big problem
is that again they are conflating
socialist redistribution programs with
socialist economies Denmark has
socialist redistribution programs we
have to assess whether those are
successful on their own merits Denmark
is not a socialist economy Denmark is a
freer economy than the United States it
has higher tax rates that's the
redistributionist part but in terms of
business regulation in terms of capacity
to attract foreign investment with free
markets Denmark is significantly more
free than the United States in fact in
2015 Denmark's prime minister explained
quote I know that some people in the
u.s. associate the Nordic model with
some sort of socialism therefore I would
like to make one thing clear Denmark is
far from a socialist plant economy
Denmark is a market economy this is
exactly right the Heritage Foundation a
right-wing source this is their ranking
of economic freedom Switzerland right
ranks 4th Denmark 12th Sweden 15th the
Netherlands 17th the United States the
evil rapacious capitalist United States
ranks 18th and economic freedom
according to the Heritage Foundation
Norway that socialist hotbed ranks 23rd
what made all of these countries wealthy
by the way is the fact that they are
capitalists and that they were more
capitalist in the past
capitalism makes countries wealthy
socialism simply takes all that wealth
and redistributes it shutting down
industry in the process and here's the
proof that all these countries were
doing well long before they had
socialism the proof is that by
Statistics this is the case number one
by statistics the case number two if you
take all these people from Denmark from
Norway from Sweden and you actually
transplant them to the United States
they have higher incomes in the United
States and they do in all these other
places actually earn more and they do
better economically so the idea that
socialism is what creates awesomeness in
these cultures is not right hey culture
created an awesomeness in these cultures
and then socialism was a follow on that
has actually tamp down the economy in
these various countries when you take
that culture and you transplant it to a
free country like the United States
where tax rates are lower then all these
cultures thrive in the United States as
well
now Nordic countries do have high levels
of social services because they charge
exorbitant taxes Denmark has a 60 point
3 percent tax rate plus a 25 percent
national say
tax which is why everything cost an arm
and leg in Denmark between 2007 and 2015
not surprisingly Denmark experienced a
5.5 percent decline in real GDP which is
comparable to the decline in in growth
in Spain which essentially went bankrupt
during the same period the natural
result was the election of a
centre-right coalition in Denmark Sweden
another supposed socialist paradise grew
because of capitalism according to an
economic scholar named Nima's Hanlon
janji who is from Norway between 1870
and 1936 Sweden enjoyed the highest
growth rate in the industrialized world
between 1936 and 2008 the growth rate
drops at 13th out of 28 industrialized
nations between 1975 in the mid 1990s
Sweden dropped from being the 4th
richest nation in the world to the 13th
richest nation in the world and that is
a direct result of restrictions on the
economy and redistributionist programs
Norway which is the left favorite
country these days they've moved on from
Denmark and Sweden because both of those
places have elected right-wing
governments now Norway is propped up by
an enormous enormous oil find off their
coast and even their nationalized oil
companies which are now used to prop up
their social welfare programs those
companies run along private lines in
that the government basically is a major
stockholder in these companies but it's
not just government appointees who run
the companies it's people who are
supposed to run these along profit lines
the government is not actually allowed
to intervene in policy in in serious
ways in the Norwegian oil industry it's
also worth noting that in Sweden Denmark
Finland Norway the top percent of wealth
owners hold between top 10% of wealth
owners hold between 65 and 69 percent of
all wealth in those countries that's
actually not that much lower than in the
United States all of these countries
were significantly more robust
economically before they started with
their socialist nonsense and the idea
that high life expectancy in Scandinavia
is an outgrowth of socialism is not true
in 1960 Norway had the highest life
expectancy in the in the OECD followed
by Sweden Iceland and Denmark by 2005
the gap between Scandinavian countries
and the UK and the US had actually
shrunk considerably that's after the
implementation of socialism in a lot of
these countries also worth noting you
can't just take the socialist programs
of Norway which may work for a country
of 5.3 million people and apply them to
the United States where there is not the
same level of cultural cohesion cultural
homogeneity and a hiss
of exactly that sort of cohesion and
homogeneity the population of LA County
alone is double the population of Norway
you can't just take a program that works
for five people and applied to five
million and expect it to work exactly
the same way okay in just a second I'm
gonna get to the last couple of myths
about democratic socialism being pushed
by the left but first you're gonna have
to go over to Daley wire comm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire when you do
you get the rest of the show live dress
piano Clavin show live the rest of
Michael Knowles's show live you get to
be part of our mailbag which we are
doing tomorrow so get your questions in
right now go check it out also we have a
Sunday special coming up so if you
subscribe on YouTube or iTunes then you
get to see me talk to you david mamet
and all the other people who we've we've
had Sunday specials with a lot of really
great episodes over there and for $99
you get the entire package the whole
shebang plus our fabled famous leftist
tears hot or cold tumbler which you will
enjoy
I think beyond all moral bounds you'll
enjoy that that tumbler so go check that
out right now again subscribe YouTube
iTunes leave this review we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
a final two myths about democratic
socialism so we are also hearing the
democratic socialism is the solution
when it comes to the medical industry
what we really need is to nationalize
our health care system now let's be
clear there are lots of different
government schemes with regards medicine
America's scheme does kind of suck okay
because it is not a free-market system
the great lie about America's medical
system is that it is free-market it is
not it is the most heavily regulated
area of American life the profit margins
for insurance companies in the health
insurance industry are like 2% they are
not that high and one of the reasons
that the health insurance system sucks
in the United States is because of
employer-based insurance programs which
will cram down by the government in the
1950s basically in the 1950s we had wage
controls and in order to edge around
those wage controls to give people
raises companies started paying for
their employees health insurance but
there's no reason that your health
insurance should be tied to your job
really you should just be paying for
your health insurance yourself that's
what happens in Switzerland which is
probably the world's most successful
health care system the way that
Switzerland works is that you are
mandated just like Obama care you are
mandated on the individual level to buy
your health insurance but there's no
employer-based insurance in Switzerland
plus they penalize you pretty heavily if
you don't buy health insurance if you
don't buy health insurance and then you
get sick and then you go in for care
then they will force you not only to pay
a surcharge of like 50% on your health
insurance bill they will also back
charge you for all the health insurance
you should have been paying for the last
several years Switzerland has a very
very robust program in force to force
people to buy their own health insurance
virtually it is also worth noting that
all of these other countries that
supposedly have wonderful health care
systems have their drawbacks as well
Canada of course has very long wait
lines the same thing is true in the UK
in Australia a large percentage of the
population by supplemental health
insurance on the private market so it's
not just a matter of a universal health
care system in Australia and they're
facing some significant financial issues
because of the ageing of the population
when people talk socialized medicine as
the be-all end-all
they're also forgetting that virtually
all medical advances in the
industrialized world are coming out of
the United States the u.s. is
responsible for 44% of all new molecular
entities which would be the drugs that
you actually take and that those numbers
would be a lot higher if not for
government regulation from the FDA we
also drive medical innovation in other
countries the truth is that the American
healthcare market where people are able
to charge what these drugs are
earth actually subsidizes the rest of
the world so when Canada collectively
bargains with a drug company to provide
them a certain number of drugs they're
able to do that because the United
States is paying a higher price because
we are paying a higher price in the
private market for all of that so
they're exploiting all these drug
companies are basically exploiting the
private market and then making deals on
the back end with all these socialized
medicine systems if the United States
when socialized medicine the prices
would skyrocket for everyone on drugs
because nobody would be subsidizing this
stuff anymore
also it is still true if you've got the
money America is the best place to be
for medicine if you've got the cash then
America is still the best place to be
even more like that if we could do
regulate the system okay final lie final
lie the Democratic Socialist tell is
that capitalism is giant failure this is
the dumbest argument of all capitalism
is the most dramatic success in the
history of the world people living on a
dollar a day or or less that fell from
about 27 percent of the global
population in 1970 all the way down to
five point four percent in 2006 that's
an 80% decline poverty worldwide
included ninety four percent of the
world's population in 1820 in 2011 it
was down to 17 percent mortality rates
for kids under the age of five declined
by nearly half
between 1990 and 2013 virtually no
American lives in go in poverty by
global standards so the third plank of
the Democratic platform which is this
economic democratic socialism
it's a giant fail it's a giant fell on
every score and the fact that it's even
being considered by the Democrats
demonstrates how far left they have
moved right now now in just a second I
want to talk about the latest with
regard to President Trump and
witch-hunts and Paul Manafort and and
all the rest you know there there's
there's a lot to talk about there but
final note when it comes to the
Democrats kind of socialist platform
here the final note is that the only
thing that will allow Americans to vote
for a platform this radical an
intersectionality based subjective
morality based democratic socialism
based platform is if the Republican
Party just sucks at things really we
have such a great story to tell
conservatism has a great story to tell a
story about individual human freedom
about individual rights inalienable
rights about the the right to life about
the value of life about the value of a
serious morality that has consequences
for your daily life about the idea of
hard work and achievement
ah cracy if we blow that opportunity and
hand it over to these idiots if we blow
that opportunity and hands it over to
this radical program that's a referendum
on our inability to sell the greatest
honestly the greatest system that has
ever been devised by God or man I mean
it's it's it's it's really an impressive
failure on the part of conservatives if
they can't sell this stuff okay speaking
of which the President of the United
States is once again going after Jeff
Sessions so on Wednesday he called on
Attorney General Jeff Sessions to end
the special counsel inquiry into
Russia's interference in the 2016
election he issued an unambiguous
directive on Twitter to shut down an
investigation that even now is
scrutinizing his tweets for evidence of
instructions and the left immediately
has jumped to this means that Trump is
actually obstructing this is clearly
obstruction well it's actually not
clearly obstruction the reason I can say
it's not clearly obstruction is because
in fact he didn't fire robert muller he
has the power to fire robert muller he
has the power
more importantly as the power to fire
sessions the power the power to fire
Rosenstein he can do whatever he wants
he's the head of the executive branch he
didn't fire him so this is indeed Trump
mouthing off with that said is it smart
for Trump to mouth off on this sort of
stuff no it's not particularly smart of
the President to to mouth off on this
kind of stuff like for example the
president shouldn't didn't just mouth
off about the Muller investigation
he also mouthed off about the mana for
trial it's a Paul Manafort is his former
campaign manager ran the campaign for
something like four months I actually
believe that Trump didn't really know
who he was because he was sort of an RNC
insider who was appointed by the RNC to
help Trump run his campaign and then he
was out as soon as bad story started to
break about Paul Manafort a man-of-war
is now on trial for fraud and Trump
tweeted out that even Alphonse Capone
was not treated with this sort of
disdain with which they are treating
Paul Manafort why is the president
defending Paul Manafort the Manafort
trial has nothing to do with Russian
collusion the Manta floor trial has
nothing to do with the 2016 election all
of the charges being brought against
Paul Manafort pre-exists the election
cycle of 2016 and why the president
wants to jump in here with both feet is
absolutely beyond me it doesn't make any
sense except I think he's just so angry
and Mullah right now that he's willing
to to basically rip on anything team
Muller does which isn't a particularly
good look I'll also say in poem anna
forts defense the prosecution has
focused
apparently an awful lot on the clothing
that he bought with alleged russian
money so I mean well here here's what
the Prada prosecution has
evidence that po-man afford spends
$15,000 on a jacket made of ostrich I am
not kidding he's like mr. burns from The
Simpsons he's got a mess he's got a vest
made of real gorilla chest he's got a
$15,000 ostrich jacket he also has a
$9,500 ostrich vest and I think most
importantly he has an $18,500 Python
jacket I think that I think that there
is a solid case to be made that we
should exonerate him based on his
wardrobe choices I think that if you
can't use Russian money to buy a
nineteen thousand dollar Python jacket
this is no longer America you there's no
friend listen America this is America
okay America you get to buy a nineteen
thousand dollar Python jacket if you
want to buy a nineteen thousand dollar
Python jacket actually this is kind of
funny so a did the judge in the manna
for trial actually scolded the lawyers
for bringing all this stuff up judge
Ellis he said the government doesn't
want to prosecute someone because they
were nice clothes do they let's move on
that's enough so I kind of appreciate
the judge for doing all that and I agree
again if I decide to go out and I just
had to make a jacket out of gopher heads
that is my prerogative and fur cost me
19 thousand dollars in putin's money
that's my prerogative - man come on this
is still America
now they here's the problem with all of
this obviously for president Trump the
more president from focuses in on the
Moller investigation the less we are
talking about all of the great messages
that conservatism has to provide the
less we are talking about the failures
of the Democratic program the less we
are talking about socialism versus
capitalism unless we're talking about
inalienable rights versus government
intervention ISM if you're not talking
about those things then you are failing
to paint the left for what they are if
you're talking instead about robert
muller is the worst and paul manna for
its innocent no it's just a distraction
from the program that republicans can
sell right now a great economy based on
increase in capitalistic principles of
reduction of regulation and tax cuts
it's a pretty good sales pitch but the
Republicans aren't making it right now
at all and that is and that is deeply
problematic in a number of ways if
President Trump wants to have a
Republican Congress even cares about
that then it is incumbent on him to
start talking about the issues that
matter in a way that actually gets
people jazzed up for the election and
isn't just self-serving narcissism
navel-gazing
okay so let's do a couple of things I
like and then we'll do a couple of
things that I hate so well
I was on the plane I finally watched the
movie Steve Jobs Danny Boy was the
director and I would say this is the
thing I am lukewarm on I wouldn't say
this is a thing that I like I will say
Michael Fassbender is probably my
favorite actor working today or at least
one of the top three
it's like Christian Bale Daniel
day-lewis Michael Fassbender I think
maybe for me not necessarily in that
order properly day-lewis bail and then
Fassbender in any case Michael
Fassbender
stars as Steve Jobs doesn't look
anything like Steve Jobs but he's a
great actor so he's able to pull it off
what that's what I like about the film
is that fast benders performance is
really terrific the things I don't like
about the film or that the score is
egregiously bad I mean the score is just
hysterical and overwrought in every
conceivable way and the script is
written by Aaron Sorkin which means that
every character is Aaron Sorkin's when
Kate Winslet is acting in this film it's
Aaron Sorkin with a wig is one of the
problems with with Aaron Sorkin's
writing generally is that there's no
characterization whatsoever everything
is all about the fast patter it's like
sort of watching an upscale Gilmore
Girls like an upscale episode of the
Gilmore Girls in any case here's a
little bit of the preview for Steve Jobs
which is it worth seeing yes is it a
great movie No is it you know mildly
entertaining and diverting yeah I think
so what do you do you're not an engineer
you're not a designer
you can't put a hammer to a nail I built
the circuit board the graphical
interface was stolen
so how come ten times in a day I read
Steve Jobs as a genius what do you do
musicians play their instruments I play
the orchestra you see how this reminds
you have a friendly face it's the entire
movies built basically around three set
pieces where our Fassbender it plays
jobs it's sort of the launch of the
original Mac which is a failure and then
the launch of next which is also a
failure and then the launch of the of
the eye Mac which which was a success in
1998 so it's it's kind of interesting
we're worth checking out so go check
that out
right now okay now let's let's do a few
things that I hate let's do it okay so
voxcom has an article today about a Pew
survey which has found that Americans
say they pray more than any other
wealthy nation 55% of Americans report
that they pray at least once daily six
percentage points higher than the
International average well that may not
seem like a big gap on its own America
is an extreme statistical outlier when
it comes to countries with at least a
thirty thousand dollar per person GDP so
in this category the global average
hovers around forty percent so in Canada
for example only twenty five percent of
people pray daily that number is 22
percent in Europe 18 percent in
Australia and six percent in Great
Britain in other words with great wealth
comes less religiosity in the United
States we're still a relatively
religious country and 55 percent of
Americans report praying at least once
daily voxcom of course think this is
because we're stupid and backwards and
we're a bunch of bitter clingers who
cling to our God and our guns I think
this is because America is freaking
amazing because it really is and one of
the things that you learn when you study
the Bible is that people don't stop
worshipping God when bad things happen
this is one of the great lies of atheism
is that the reason people fall away from
God is bad stuff happens to them and
they look around at the universe and
they say why would a child suffer there
must be no God that's not the real
reason really why people stop being
religious and worshiping God and praying
the real reason people stop worshipping
God and praying is because they look
around things are pretty good what do I
need God for maybe you people get fat
and happy and they think that they did
it themselves and then they feel like
God is superfluous why do I need to
thank God for anything what am i praying
for everything is pretty great and it
was created by a bunch of scientists who
don't believe in God
so what the hell do I need this this
whole god thing for the reason that
religiosity is important particularly in
an industrialized civilized society is
because that is what ties us to basic
fundamental principles and those basic
fundamental principles are in fact the
the lines of thought that undergird
Western civilization you would not have
that iPhone in your hand were not for
the Bible you would not have that iPhone
in your hand were not for Greek reason
combined with a biblical sense of
morality because capitalism is based on
certain principles those principles
include inalienable rights in you you
have inalienable value you are worth
something your labor is worth something
you as an individual are made in God's
image and you are more important than
any collective that is put together in
order to crush or write on behalf of
some sort of communal priority I mean
all of that is rooted in a certain
fundamental biblical morality that is
based again on the most important
sentence I think in human history the
most important sentence in human history
is not in my opinion treat thy neighbor
as thyself love thy neighbor as thyself
it is not do not unto others what you
would have not not have them do unto you
I think the most important sentence in
human history is that man was made in
God's image that is the most in in male
and female he created them at that image
from Genesis is the most important verse
in the history of humanity and it is the
beginning of all wisdom and the
beginning of all human rights so I'm
deeply grateful that America is still
the most religious country it's the
reason why we are the world leader
everybody else can basically climb on
our backs because the reality is that
this country with our backwardness and
our religion and our church-going it has
been driving the global economy for nigh
on for well over a century for well over
a century okay other things that I hate
today so the media are still in
full-scale weeping mode for themselves
so Jim Acosta
is still going on national TV whining
about the fact that he went to a trump
rally and people yelled at him is it
good that people yelled at him in a
trump rally no it's not I said yesterday
I think it's more like a sporting event
to people than it really is like I wish
I I would hate Jim Acosta the way you
can tell this is when the cameras go off
they immediately go up and they want to
take pictures with Jim Acosta right they
treat Jim Acosta as though he's the
rival sports star on on another team so
they sort of treat like LeBron James a
Laker now Celtics fans treat LeBron
James the way that Trump fans treat Jim
Acosta basically that LeBron probably
comes to the Boston Garden or whatever
they
call it now and the and he plays and
everybody boos him they say that he's a
traitor and they say he's terrible and
then after the game they are clamoring
for an autograph if you go to Trump
rallies that's actually the way that a
cost is sort of treated people yell at
him they scream at him it's fun it's fun
to say that CNN sucks cuz CNN does in
many cases suck and then Jim Acosta and
then and then they go up and take
pictures of the Casta well Acosta is
still complaining about this suggesting
that we're not in America anymore by the
way he came out this morning and
attacked Sean Hannity and said that Sean
Hannity is a terrible human so it's okay
to attack other members of the media
it's just not okay for anybody to back
Jim Acosta here is Jim Acosta talking
about his core of his horrifying
experiences it just I mean brutal brutal
terrible this isn't America anymore it's
just like back in the Soviet Union where
they'd stack you up at the bottom of the
of the KGB building where the floors
were slanted to catch all the blood and
then they'd shoot you it's exactly like
that except that Jim Acosta got his hair
messed up a little bit not by anybody
throwing anything about Adam but just
because he was so frustrated so here's
Jim Acosta
you know honestly it felt like we
weren't in America anymore I don't know
how to put it any more plainly than that
Americans should not be treating their
fellow Americans in this way I agree
talk to Maxine Waters talk to talk to
members van Tifa talk to all of these
other folks on the Left who have been
willing to do this for a very long time
but apparently you are our special Jim
Acosta and so you know it didn't happen
until it happened to you right until it
happened to you is no big deal it's just
like it's amazing the media only
discovered that the alt-right were a
bunch of jackasses when the alt-right
started attacking people on the left
right though they all right start
attacking Julia Jaffe for example and
suddenly the alt-right was a thing
I think months of alt-right abuse but
that was totally okay because I was on
the right obviously and the the media is
selective coverage is one of the reasons
why people don't trust the media at all
you see the same thing from ABC's sunny
Hostin who's over on the view she says
that President Trump's attacks on the
press are like the acts of a dictator
jobs are to report the facts and I think
that's one of the reasons why this
president has started this war against
the media because he doesn't like that
the truth is being reported and I think
that means that that is journalists you
have to continue to do so these are the
acts in my opinion of a dictator
dictators
attack the press routinely okay yeah
it's just like a dictator except that
when dictators attacked the press they
then go and shoot members of the press
they Vladimir Putin actual just didn't
go see kills people so it's just like
that except for he says a lot of dumb
stuff on Twitter so exactly the same
pretty much exactly the same okay well
will you'll be back here tomorrow with
the mailbag so if you have your
questions you need to subscribe now and
then ask those questions and you'll have
a better chance of me answering those
questions and making your life just
infinitely better go check it out right
now daily wire.com we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018